look I know I got something on besides a
t-shirt it's laundry day my lunch big
the opposites still don't change the
fact I'm not wearing pants what's up
Balu this booty look Oh what's going on
YouTube now easily for those of you who
have not heard there has been a bit of
an uproar because of what Raven Symone
said about heard ejecting her label as
an African American because if you saw
that interview you should have stopped
off his face even she was like oh
there's you on your own I'm like it's
[ __ ] get it on as an Oprah Winfrey
Network okay well I tried now before we
go ahead and get into this I'm not mad
at you Raven and I don't think a lot of
us should be but I am gonna break a
couple things down for you to why people
are in a bit of an outrage to what you
stated in that video you said and I
quote I'm an American I'm not an African
American I am an American some people
took this as you saying that you do not
want to be black and I'm here to tell
you guys that's not what she was saying
at all what she was trying to say is
that she was tired of being labeled and
categorized now the Profeta statement is
not the intent is more than ill fire
behind it Raven you did not think before
you said that statement here's something
that everybody needs to get straight
right now despite what you wanted what
you think we do not live in a colorless
world on only one race the human
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up listen I grew up
in school when people told me that
everybody is the same color and nobody
else is different from the next but
here's the thing that's [ __ ] stupid
now before you go ahead and get your
pubes in a French braid I need you to
listen carefully you do not tease
somebody about love tolerance and
acceptance by telling them that the only
way for you to be accepted as an equal
is by ridding yourself of your cultural
background see a lot of you guys out
there get invoked up because you think
that tolerance and acceptance happens
when you tell people that you are not
different and that's wrong because yes
people of different ethnicities cultures
and backgrounds are different but that's
the beauty of it you teach people about
blue you are and where you're from
that's outside of your cultural bubble
to fall in love with your differences
that's what it's about so what I'm
trying to say to you Raymond is think
about what you want and what I just said
despite the fact that you don't like the
African that is attached to your
American it is there listen I know you
don't give two [ __ ] about me and even
if you saw this video you still would
not care but coming from a person of
color that lives in this country that
quote unquote label on your chest that
you wear as an a tag should be worn on
top of your head as a crown now another
problem with your statement is also
based on your social status you can
probably say today that you do not want
to be labeled as african-american and
you're good to go but not everybody else
has that privilege now what do I mean by
that it's weird with a handful of
successful and rich people that they
forget that when money and power isn't
involved they're just kind of hard to
erase that color of your skin
for example racial profiling racial
persecution is not something that a lot
of us can escape we don't really have
that option and when you put out a
statement like that it's almost like
you're saying that you want some sort of
like racial gentrification now I'm not
using this to defend people who use
their ethnicity as a crutch because I
[ __ ] hate those people too but when
you make a public statement that you
want to dissociate yourself from the
African a part of your American and you
kind of spit in the face of a lot of
people before you write there were four
fathers of color before you that we're
labeling things ten times worse than
that
that it worked hard with their blood
sweat and tears to make sure that that
label that you hate so much was put into
a light of admiration my point is is
that a lot of us out there don't have
the privilege of just leaving our color
behind it's not a real
solution to the problem you know as a
final statement I'm just gonna say this
because this is something that resonated
with me as a kid and that was told to me
so I hope that resonates with a lot of
you is that when we look at a tree a lot
of times we just fall in love with the
leaves but we forget about the roots to
held it all together
oh wait going on YouTube [ __ ]
let's redo that mmm
raise it raising about the culture
raisin raisin you forget now I'm not
using this the vendors I like and I hope
that when I say this
ah there's been a bit of an uproar
because yeah because why David is you
choking on your [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] together